so Donald Trump has blocked the release
of the Democratic memo responding to the
Republican Devin Nunez memo and this has
become sort of the culmination of
hypocrisy built on incompetence within
an environment of total paranoia right
so to reset the background for you
there's an investigation going on into
Donald Trump's possible collusion with
Russia and related crimes that's
probably not a surprise to you but
certainly it's relevant to setting up
the context of these memos it's being
carried out by the special prosecutor
Robert Muller former FBI director put in
place after the firing of former FBI
director James Comey and some weeks ago
Republicans started pushing this
narrative that Devon Nunez Republican
congressman from California wrote a memo
that supposedly exposed that the FBI had
been engaged in just horrible misdeeds
and wrongdoing and that as a result the
Muller investigation had lost
credibility and the entire thing should
be shut down so a huge back-and-forth
ensued over whether or not the Nunez
memo should have been released and at
the time both the Department of Justice
and the FBI publicly we're saying don't
release the memo it alludes to and
references classified information
information about intelligence gathering
techniques that the United States
intelligence apparatus employs and Trump
because he was so eager to try to
discredit Muller ignored those
recommendations and release the memo
anyway now we'll later in the program
get to the reality kind of a sad reality
a scary reality that Trump probably
never actually read the new Ness memo so
he didn't even really know what was in
it and of course it didn't disgrace
robert muller or the investigation the
memo that trump released the new Ness
memo ended up being accusations unproven
accusations of course because neither we
nor Devon Nunez saw the underlying
intelligence accusations about
FISA warrant applications again no real
impact on the Moller investigation and
it appears in every instance that robert
muller has acted 100% correctly so then
after the very anticlimactic release of
the Devon Nunez memo we learned that
Democrats have a memo of their own which
is a response memo to the memo is of
Devon Nunez it's like memo chain right I
mean it we're all wrapped up in memos
here but again the release of the
Democratic memo also has to be okayed by
the President of the United States now
Trump initially said well I will seek
the recommendation of the Department of
Justice and our intelligence agencies
about whether to release the Democratic
memo or whether or not to release it
which is already hilarious right because
the DOJ and other Intel agencies said
don't release the new Nest memo Trump
did it anyway and then now Trump says
well I'm gonna defer to those same
agencies that I ignored last time
because he just wanted to release the
Nunez memo so on the Democratic memo the
DOJ at least publicly doesn't say that
they're concerned about the release of
the memo presumably there were elements
that the DOJ would have wanted redacted
or our intelligence agencies would have
wanted redacted from the Democratic memo
but that would have been handled
privately no public statements were made
by our intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agency is saying don't
release the Democratic memo but Donald
Trump blocked it anyway Donald Trump
decided not to release them the memo and
his attorney put out a statement saying
although the president is inclined to
declassify the memo in question called
the February 5th memorandum because the
memorandum contains numerous properly
classified and especially sensitive
passages he is unable to do so at the
time now of course the reality is that
given the release of the Nunez memo this
memo should have also been released and
Republican not Democratic Republican
congressman Justin Amash
said it very clearly when he tweeted a
couple of days ago both the Republican
and Democratic FISA memos should be
released I've read both memos neither
one in dangers national security the
American people deserve the opportunity
to read both memos what people need to
understand here is this is all a mere
political football this was never about
exposing actual wrongdoing by actors
regardless of political implications
from the start this was meant just to
interfere with the Russia investigation
period it backfired because the new Ness
memo alleged some minor concerns in
terms of FISA applications but is in no
way shape or form an indictment or
discrediting of the robert muller
investigation there are no real concerns
in terms of how robert Moeller is
carrying forward this investigation but
if the goal here was it was to expose
any and all wrongdoing that means you
should release the Democratic memo for
transparency right so that we can figure
out well what do the Democrats counter
allege about the Devon Nunez memo that
was originally released the Selective
publication of one memo and not the
other when there are no valid national
security concerns for handling these two
memos differently confirms that the only
goal here is to try to stop Robert
Muller and actually that plays into it
arguably becomes part of the growing
number of attempts made by the Trump
administration to get in the way of
Robert Muller's probe and the memo may
still come to light Democrats could
conceivably call for a vote to override
Donald Trump's decision not to release
this it's unclear if they will the memo
could be leaked at some point I don't
know if ever if we will ever ultimately
see the memo but the important thing is
that this charade has completely exposed
the entire memo thing which from the
beginning was pretty clearly a
distraction from the investigation
itself it is exposed via
tire thing as a completely partisan
political football of no objective value
importance or significance when it comes
to Robert molars actual investigation
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership